guy branham what a guy that's why they
named him guys the best of the best and
you're about to discover him if you
haven't yet or
bask in his gloriousness
if you're not already aware
hey mitzi i'm guy branham happy holidays
to you and
all of your audience uh i myself am
jewish so i'm celebrating a holiday
not the holiday that's the thing around
christmas time is that christmas is
magical
it changes what's on tv what's on the
radio it makes plucky journalists fall
in love with princes on netflix
like hanukkah by comparison is just like
a lighting fixture
like it's just a little pathetic
compared to the way that
christmas changes the world like when
you think about it you remember back
when gay people couldn't get married we
could only get domestic partnership
which was like all the legal rights of a
marriage but none of the like magic or
romance
that's what hanukkah is it's the
domestic partnership of holidays
and a couple of years ago i was at home
in northern california
and my whole family was there um my mom
and my niece and my cousin and her kids
and my mom
was like get these kids out of our hair
make go play dreidel with them and
let me be clear no one likes playing
dreidel
like there everything about hanukkah is
a little bit pathetic
except for lakas but like dreidel it's
just like you're spinning a little top
it's not fun
to anyone except for a three-year-old
which my nephew was
for a three-year-old dreidel is
operating at the height of all of your
skills
you're having to operate a small object
recognize four letters in a foreign
alphabet
and have to count at times up to seven
it is the equivalent of you or me having
to fly a jet plane
like my nephew or cousin's kid was so
exhilarated
that at one point he was like uncle he
calls me uncle
uncle we are playing a game
so after like 20 minutes my niece who is
12 got bored because anyone gets bored
playing dreidel
and she was like uncle can we be done
can i have a piece of gelt
and i was like sure and over the course
of the game the little boy
jacob had just been winning over and
over again until he had this enormous
pile of guilt that he was sitting on top
of like a little jewish dragon
and i i was like do you want a piece of
your gals and he was confused
and so i handed a piece of like one of
the gold coins to him
and he again just didn't know what was
going on so i unwrapped it and i put it
in his mouth
and at that point and at no point
before then did he realize that the
enormous
pile of coins he was sitting on had been
chocolate
the entire time it was like the end of
an m night shyamalan movie
his world changed in an instant
and i realized that there is magic to
hanukkah
which like all jewish magic involves
money
and eating thank you very much and happy
holidays i'm guy brent
that was bananas i want more thanks for
coming to bananas
[Applause]
more